bring all your lovers and friends for
cookouts and reunions are some of the
best summer escapes you'll see what i
did there in just a minute and you know
you better have your food and your
playlist ready and to help with that we
have a very special guest in the kitchen
yes today let's welcome tamika scott a
member of the multi-platinum r b
group iconic
escape
hey girl hey
okay so before we talk about what you do
on the stove let's talk about what
you're doing on stage this weekend girl
we are going to show out it is going to
be an amazing show
uh escape of course we have usher monica
tlc swv and the list goes on nothing but
just hits after hits after hit i already
know and i can imagine like being on my
sidekick in a lovers and friend's group
chat or something what are you guys all
saying about coming together again
star friends we love it we have fun you
know we we come out we sing we support
each other while we're on stage we on
the side like you better do it girl
yes so much fun so what are you looking
forward to performing the most what
songs can we expect i want to say
who can i run to i'm gonna sign it oh
i'm gonna suck it oh oh
i caught myself like girl
girl oh my gosh who can i run to is one
of my favorite songs so it's one of ours
we're gonna kill it oh it's classic we
can't wait we can't wait so that is this
weekend but now let's move on to the
kitchen what do you like to listen to
while you cook girl i like to listen to
all types of music like my favorite
singer is michael bolton so when a man
loves a woman
i can cook good when he's singing baby
okay well then let's get to it what are
we making i am making my c italian
instead of lasagna i'm going to do my
tortellini
okay okay so we're going to start with a
little butter i already started melting
the butter and it smells so good in here
and that's something you're used to when
people walk into your home it's like oh
something smells good yeah like every
time somebody comes in my home they are
eating
they come and they say this is what we
want this is what i want and i try to
cater to everybody i love that i'm going
to start off with baby spinach okay
fresh baby spinach get your greens get
your girls you know what they say back
well you're too young to know this book
back in the day i used to watch popeye
the sailor man okay and they said that
it gives you muscles girl i have yet to
see them also honey
i'm still it's okay it goes it goes
other places that we appreciate oh yeah
yeah i have the muscles
so there's the spinach and we're going
to let this saute a little bit and i'm
going to use my seasoning i have my own
seasoning line called tamika scott
southern fuse okay okay so we're going
to use a little all-purpose in here and
that's just one part of the brand okay
there's a cookbook there's all these
things that we will get to yeah just a
little bit
and i know we don't have that much time
but we're going to let that simmer and
obviously this is a very balanced meal
very bad does this go into all of your
recipes balance
italian we're doing soul food what's
that what's in the cookbook oh in the
cookbook cooking with tamika scott you
have your drinks yes i have my adult
beverages so let's see girls i have a
lot of different recipes for my glam
babies my daughters it's like a family
family affair all of my recipes are
attached to a story of why i love that
recipe that's beautiful and where did
you get the inspiration to come up with
the cookbook girl my husband has been
saying baby you need to do a cookbook
you need to do a cookie we love a
supportive husband yes very supportive i
am adding in my cream sauce this right
here has white wine okay
everybody's cream sauce is different you
know so you got a little special touch
on this one it's a little southern with
a little white wine and my little my
occasion fuse we're going to just mix
this in a little wow together and this
is something really simple too which i
love for people you know like myself yes
so simple fun and delish okay yes yes
yes yes what are some other um what are
some other recipes examples that we can
get well i have my smacking mac and
macaroni and cheese make you want to
snack somebody girl love that a little
soul food yes just a little bit we're
going to add our
toilet tinies tort to chocolate
i think we just started something girl
yes it is stuffed with spinach and
ricotta cheese oh my god it's amazing so
it's twerking in the sauce girl
you know what no really i think you just
started something with that i think you
just saw some stuff now how can people
get the book it's releasing yes
christmas 17th it is being is out you
can go to hunter publishing bookstore
okay you can go to barnes nobles and
amazon.com
simple as that and um i understand that
you know even though this is not out you
can follow you on social media things of
that nature the real tamika scott okay
we're going to add our crab
oh my god that's what makes it the sea
the sea italian
crab meat or shrimp
wow and for people who might be a little
afraid
in the kitchen you know not you know not
have as much experience what do you have
to say to them let's give some advice to
everybody out there buy my cookbook
hello and it's going to give you all the
easy recipes recipes that my
eight-year-old daughter can make oh see
okay
i'm inspired i'm going to add in the
salmon wow
will you be cooking this weekend for
your girls co-stars no ma'am
you know what i had the opportunity i
had the opportunity to cater um the
verses with myself my group and swb yeah
such a good one those girls so picky
girl
that rider i was like hold on lobster
lobster right girl i had to go cook
prepare sing battle right all of that
all of that the beauty of being a woman
okay so i gotta taste it now because we
got about okay less than 30 seconds all
right girl okay okay okay we're having
so much fun i know i know and obviously
this is the finished product your
finished product look at here it's
beautiful for the entire family
yes
cooking with tamika scott make sure you
go to hunter publishing bookstore okay
amazon.com
or barnes noble get your copy now you
can go to southernfuse.com to get my
delicious gluten-free non-preser no
preservatives
oh i'm trying to hurry up girl girl no
please you're good you're good we are
just honored to have you in our kitchen
okay usually i played better than this
but honey we on the time listen listen
thank you and again amen amen amen and
again you're performing this weekend
with escape lovers and friends
jc
wow
oh that's so good
um
j.c i'm sending it to you all right got
it jc